the power dynamic had changed a bit but
today looks like his new toy the catalan
is actually doing him serving him well
mm-hmm
and yeah
went f7 f6 i was wondering about that
not because i like the move but because
it feels like
staying passive will not work and this
is the one
way black has of not staying passive but
it probably just ends up losing you the
game faster
because your position just starts
collapsing faster after knight c2 we
don't even need to play a four i think
we just go knight c2
and uh fed just creates more pressure
against the center
without really generating any of the
threats
threatening this way
yeah you should
is like the most obvious threat we don't
even need to be fancy magnus now he's
won two in a row before this then he
draws sam if he wins this one today
which looks like he'll have a little
three and a half out of four spurs
already
so yeah yeah yeah absolutely
we've seen this movie before yeah and
shark did resign after magnus so we
suddenly have a an influx of uh
uh finished games and uh decisive
finnish games as well